he's Carlos Boozer the host of a new
podcast through Sports Illustrated
called hold that
hol dat with his best friend Nate
Robinson I love Nate you can find it on
Apple podcast or wherever you get your
podcasts good to have you in the
building here how tall is Nate Robinson
May is about five eight five nine okay
but why no he's great he's in great
shape I don't know if you guys follow
more than Instagram he works out like a
Hannam where be like he still 25 he's
doing a lot this summer we got the big
three coming up and we're gonna start
playing than that and he's also we also
run a flag football league to son with
Terrell Owens and otro Cinco and Michael
Vick are you any good at football I got
some good hands man yeah and I got a
pretty good body spy I do pretty well
okay Nate play defensive back in
Washington yeah he also ran some
kickbacks on special teams to could
you've played it Duke football when I
was there probably at probably when we
were there we weren't very good at
football they've gotten dramatically
better since I left but we made a couple
of bowl games the last few years but
when I was there I definitely would've
been inside in there a defensive end
knockin somebody's block off well you
could have been like a Julius Peppers no
no way he was phenomenal
I know yeah I played against them on the
basketball court was he any good in
basketball yeah Amica Quinn meal think
about a guy his size
when milling on the court it was
incredible windmill Duncan yeah best
athlete you ever played against was who
uh I probably ought to say LeBron you
know better than Mike did you I played
against Mike at the enemy came back and
wrapped a retirement with the Wizards
okay we're still I mean obviously at
that he was at the tail in but like in
his prime I had to be LeBron but was
Mike when he came back with the Wizards
still talking trash oh yeah like he gave
us I mean we were we were very young we
were very young but he gave us almost
tripled I'll be like thirty three point
nine nine assists I'm like 11 rebound it
was incredible at 40 but what do you
remember about that like you're just
getting into the league I'm kind of like
in awe because I'm like you know I got
I'm gonna chance to play against when
I'm on my basketball idols and he's
still great and even though we're 19 20
years old he's giving us the business
but I was still like Anna like well you
shine will you sign this ball for me
even though you're busting our butt you
know will you sign this for me so it was
kind of a haul moment for me well plus
he's North Carolina and you're Duke -
yeah still smj did you get an autograph
yeah actually I won the locker room talk
talking before I could get like ten
minutes I didn't sign this you for me
yeah you're not supposed to do that are
you did you do that with anybody else
no he was only a guy no other player you
know you know I have I have a bunch of
science stuff that we like trade astana
like a garden and Yao Ming and Dirk and
guys but like that was only got like I
just wanted his autograph it wasn't like
a hey booth let me get your jersey - hey
by the way can I get your fuzzy Mike
Mike Mike my wall is complete if I get
the Carlos Boozer - I didn't get that
part of the conversation you know I I
said this yesterday on the show two
years ago any time I brought up
comparing LeBron to Michael Jordan I'd
get shut down like people say don't even
try it you know he's not worthy of that
now it feels like we're at least
allowing for the conversation yeah and
that says a lot about what LeBron is
doing if he goes to another NBA Finals
now he's not going to be favored to win
but if he goes to another one we talked
about Jordan going six - no but look at
the number of years that LeBron has just
been in the NBA Finals yeah very
impressed so something I don't know how
if it's apples and oranges here I know
you can't compare them talent wise
because they play differently right but
I think success wise domination wise
being the best of their generation why
can't we have that discussion yeah I
think the I think it's a it's a great
discussion I have with my friends all
the time you know I got a lot of friends
I think that the torch has been passed
already do you think LeBrons better than
Michael this is what I think I can't he
be better than I think Michael is the
goat I think he inspired so many players
include we're not even talking about
Kobe Bryant some other guys that are you
know really great but Michael was like
the you set the bar you know he got
inspired by dr. J and you know other
guys that came before him and then he
inspired the next generation think about
the Kobe Bryant's and the T max LeBron
is that great he's like a combination of
always say the combination imagine to us
and Mike
because we all know that he can lead the
league in scoring every year if he
wanted to but he's very unselfish great
playmaker and you can tell by what he's
doing right now he makes his teammates
better like there's no question that
he's he's beaten the Indiana Pacers who
I thought were a better team but he's a
more complete player than Michael I
agree with that okay I think he might be
like maybe one of the best most complete
players we've ever seen because he makes
his teammates better who would you
rather play with uh LeBron I'm gonna get
more shots with LeBron
Mike's gonna win championships yeah but
that's the thing I think about this
though think about the team's LeBrons
had to face in the finals you know and
some of the losses that he had like we
talked about one year he didn't have
Kyrie or or Kevin Love in the finals and
he still played amazing but they lost no
one year you said I can't remember the
rest of guys on their team maybe except
for Ilgauskas when they played against
the Spurs
well that's the worst team ever played
you still got there but you're playing
against the Spurs who are you know yes
in dari the dynasty loaded with for Hall
of Fame you know and Popovich so some of
the finals and he's obviously playing
against Golden State who may be one of
the best offensive teams we've ever seen
in the history of basketball so the
teams that he's facing in the finals
maybe with the exception of that Dallas
team who got extremely hot with with
Jason Kidd and Dirk Nowitzki and arrest
those guys he's played to get some
incredible incredible championship teams
we have a problem with Dirk Nowitzki
jumper where he sticks the leg out yeah
I mean he can put it right in your groin
or your chest
yeah why do they allow that I don't know
I mean when I got in the league mailman
was jumping through people with the leg
in your chest too but uh I mean I
remember I got some of those when I was
a rookie bar was too bad dude he was one
he was a made great friend of mine
amazing dude and he was just a there's a
grown-ass man but but Dirk especially
his touches fadeaway and it's funny
because other people have tried to adopt
that move I got seen Kevin Durant do it
I've seen LeBron do it but Dirk was a
master of that that kicked up legs
they'd away give me the moment where you
just felt helpless on the floor was
there a game go around somebody yeah my
rookie year this is actually a pretty
funny story the coach that drafted me
even with John Lucas you know John Lucas
so we get mailman comes to town it's
jazz come to town playing this Karl
Malone at halftime starting I'm a rookie
I'm like I'm like 16 17 games into my
rookie season and I got thrown in the
fire where you know we're not very good
we didn't get LeBron yet it was the year
before LeBron so anyway so halftime
comes and I'm just getting mopped up
before I mean ma'am it has like 24
points like 12 rebounds probably like 6
or 7 steals at the half I get in the
locker room and coach Lucas goes so are
you are you are you'll get his autograph
and you start playing ball or what yeah
I mean I was just he was just so
incredible to me with strong great such
ran the floor like he was 22 years old
like a deer that was my first experience
in the league and then um do you
remember
LeBron's like welcome to the end you
played one year with him yeah but his
rookie year did you have questions about
I can this kid be that good
no now after he came see the thing about
it is we had Darius miles when when he
was in high school when when Brian was
in high school we had Darius miles who
was you know touted to be one of the
best the next up-and-coming right
and so we draft LeBron obviously which
is a no-brainer and before he got to
practice I'm thinking we got we got a
lot going on we got D miles starting we
got LeBron start and we got Ricky Davis
Darden who's gonna be the point guard
like what's going on so I didn't know
where he fit between DeMuth or once
practice started it was no question that
LeBron was our best player like right
away because he passed the ball more
athletic saw the floor early very
willing to learn like he was always a
student of the game and he was that way
18 he stood that way now I saw interview
with him the other day and they were
asked him do you think the series is
over with Toronto and he said something
about no I remember doing Casey when he
was in Dallas when I was 2011 with the
Miami Heat
and he put a scheme defensively together
to beat me so I'm not gonna sit here and
say the series is over he's still a
student of the game which is very
impressive to me so you got LeBron when
he just comes into the league yeah and
then you face Mike when he was just
leaving the league yeah that's pretty
cool we're talking to Carlos Boozer
former NBA player won a championship at
Duke you can listen to his podcast with
Robinson it's called hold that hol dat
who came up on hold dat we did you did
that's actually a long story I'll tell
you that later okay yeah you can find it
on Apple podcast or wherever you get
your podcast I know you get tired of
telling the story but you got to tell
the story we're sorry
the Princeton now you rent your house to
print yeah in LA yeah
all right so set it up from there for
the audio okay so one said Utah Jazz and
I wanted to live in LA so I bought a
nice crib was in Bel Air
how much how much you spend for I spent
8 million on it okay there's like eight
points thick so it's probably worth I
mean I'll get to that it was huge it was
like 18 thousand square feet it was
immaculate it had like 10 bedrooms and
you know it was just a great house huge
pool three living rooms it wasn't
incredible anyway um it was like that Oh
mom I made it had a house you know that
we all do anyway um I want a store I got
to go back to Utah for the season it's
like it's like September now heater
starts in October so I go back to Utah
and I'm getting a phone call from my my
realtor Roxanne Del City she's like hey
someone must really rent your house out
I was like I bring lived in a house I'm
in there for one month I don't wanna
rent my house out and she goes will he's
willing to pay you know 95 grand a month
Oh 95 grand a month I was like yeah you
know I'll rent the house out so I rent
it out for a year I had to go out there
to sign the paper so on the off day I
flew out there and he comes out of a car
and his prints I'm like whoa I said
Roxanne that's prints right she's like
it he's like you know he's kind of you
know but you know who it is so I'm like
wow so I'm trying to like hold my
composure a little bit and but he was so
cool man very like broke the ice was
very huge fan of basketball he's from
Minnesota Sue's we had a great
conversation about Kevin Garnett who to
me was like one of the toughest matchups
I ever had so oh yeah great conversation
about him anyway long story short you
rinse the house out and I go back to
Utah I hurt my hamstring that year so
I'm coming back to LA to visit Judy Seto
was a great physical therapist if you
ever get banged up I got banged up last
night at sports Emmys yeah I was
actually at the gala before the show the
Lola yeah anyway
so I come to La oh I hit I hit prints up
I'm like hey I'm coming to town I'm
gonna stop by the house if you need
anything let me know and didn't hear
back from him so I go I go I go down the
street where I or I thought my house was
out I pull up to the gate and I had
these two lions on the gate and they
weren't there anymore I was like this
big symbol and I didn't know what the
Sun was I had no I was I didn't know
what the symbol was so I'm looking at
the gate I'm like I notices go back up
the street and I come back down and I'm
like this is this has got to be my house
so I put the code in and it works
gates open up and I'm like what is going
on like what's going on go off the
driveway and there's like this huge
purple carpet there's like from the
mortar from the motor court to the front
door there was like these stairs maybe
like 15 stairs that's like a red carpet
but it was a purple car but it was a
purple carpet okay with this same symbol
so he was going by the symbol back then
not I didn't know that oh so he didn't
go by prints he went by this symbol
apparently okay
so I'm like what was going so I get up
to the house open the door my ex-wife
put all this incredible like decorations
or furniture she had like what do you
call it like some kind of cream Italian
car I don't know I'm not a decorator all
this cream Italian carpet furnished a
whole and 18,000 square foot home right
I get in there and none of my stuff is
in there anymore it's all like this
black carpet it's purple couches as
black couches there's pictures of him
everywhere but I never saw that before
I'm not talking about like no you know
were they like portraits I'm talking
about like posters like you see at a
movie theater like he's like you know
Wilt Chamberlain right here you know
Willis Reed is huge everywhere um one of
the cool things about what he changed
that he changed a lot of stuff at the
house he had like one of the guest rooms
into like a hair salon one one one one
into uh hey yeah yeah one room it's
alike but he didn't make my weight room
into a disco ball nightclub we're talk
about was pretty cool I never had that
in a house before that was pretty cool
anyway
story short can you be mad at him I was
pissed you know we didn't we didn't
agree to this I'm in and then in the
contract so I'm trying to get a hold of
him calling him call him calling I'm
like I'm gonna sue you and I want some
soup French really liked me like I was
probably my my parents probably can see
me to your music so at some point it's
I'm sorry I really don't want that you
know at the end of the day um he he
reached back out to me maybe like six
weeks later and he was on tour in Asia
for his album three one two one he's
like Louis don't worry when I move out
there'll be like I was never there and
he robbed me fire from the ground to
ease my mind and it was crazy when he
moved out it was like he was never there
it was like let me just tell you how
much money princess he rented my house
for him basically a little over a
million dollars for the year he moved
all of my stuff over 18,000 square foot
fully furnished house in storage
redecorated the entire thing the way he
wanted it wide me 500k to ease my mind
moved all that stuff back out and put my
stuff back in like he was never there
and that's how much money princess
incredible did you get to play did you
ever play hoops with previous on the
rooftop it was a tennis court I turned
into a basketball courts of the day that
I'd own the roof of the yeah it was like
a rooftop terrace crazy tennis court on
the roof yeah but so the house was owned
you got too much money by the house was
owned by someone that was in the
entertainment business so he had a lot
of entertaining he wanted like a look he
built the house anyway so we shot the
first day that he came to sign it was
pretty cool he had a good shot he acts
had a good jump shot I know but we keep
hearing about Prince's game I mean I
don't know if he had game I didn't see
him play just shot around a little bit
Oh what are you guys trying to do with
the podcast like what's the goal when
you and Nate do this podcast so me and
Nate wanted to do a show where we had a
platform to talk to you know fans about
you know we're parents
you know athletes raising athletes my
kids play ball shouts my kids you guys
are gracious yes cool but we want to
give perspective of what players go
through like when you're missing your
kids are for example the the tedious
season you got games on the roll you
don't get a chance to see your kid you
know at school play but at the same time
you're getting the right morals and the
right teachings of working
art and putting your best foot forward
all the time so it's a platform for us
to speak for players and to kind of see
what they're going through today and
give our stories of what we went through
that might be similar it's called hold
dad yeah and it's with Nate Robinson you
can find it on Apple podcasts or
wherever you get your podcast if Golden
State doesn't win the title this year
finish that sentence somebody got hurt a
couple people must have got hurt it's
the only way they can lose in my opinion
I think this I'm not saying that
Houston's not very good am i saying that
LeBrons not doing something incredible
in the Eastern Conference over there and
I'm not even saying that if Boston comes
out of the East that they're not doing
something spectacular with brass Stevens
without Kyrie and and Hayward but they
are the most complete team when you look
at the last work that the team data left
I obviously we'll see what happens with
Boston and Philly
I still think Boston into winning that
tonight but regardless if you stop you
Steph Curry which is very hard to do
they got Kevin Durant if you stop Kevin
Durant which is extremely hard to do
they got klay Thompson if you start you
got
draymond Green making plays for those
other three guys it's and then on
defense they could switch everything
they're great defensive team they're
getting passing lanes they're they have
championship pedigree and then if for
some reason you get down to a one
possession game they got Steve Kerr who
was doing a phenomenal job coaching them
so I just write they have in totality
they have the best team we talked about
this do they have the best starting five
in the last 35 40 years it's a great
question I mean now I threw this out and
I didn't realize I had forgotten how
deep they were but the bad boy Pistons
very good so I got a Hall of Fame
backcourt I got Rodman I got Laimbeer
I got Vinny Johnson coming off the bench
cooking I've got I got Marco guire grace
Gore as well I got John Salley coming
off the bench Hooper active so I've got
a pretty good pretty good roster there I
mean even the Bulls though Michael
Jordan Scottie Pippen Rodman Kukoc you
know those guys John Paxson they were
very good as well maybe they won a lot
of games and won a few champions Celtics
in the mid eighties for Green Acres like
magic and Kareem worthy I mean they had
like five Hall of Famers on
but if I put that five number one pics
in one time though the other Lakers yeah
cuz they had Michael Thompson I think
and he was the number one pick but if I
put these Warriors back in the 80s or
90s we played 80s or 90s rules mm-hmm
who you got Oh imma I would I would
probably pick the Lakers because there
was nothing for Kareem like to me I
think Kareem is the most unstoppable
player of all time one of the most
underrated emotions most non talked
about great great athletes players of a
of a generation psyche made more than
that because his high school career he
was phenomenal up here in New York his
college career I think he I don't know
if he lost the game the college he lost
he lost to Houston and Elvin Hayes and
then came back and beat them in the
finals and then he's an incredible NBA
career where he's still the leading
scorer in NBA history yeah so it's just
I think he's very underrated and very
unappreciated but he was I would pick
them because he had an unstoppable shot
from anywhere on the court
what if LeBron ends up the old-time
leading scorer let's see doesn't he does
it when she could though yes but he
doesn't win another championship but
he's a top-10 and assists yeah and
probably top ten in steals and the
number one scorer of all time yeah I
think I think I'll have a strong
argument as maybe the best player when
you'd love to see Mike in LeBron who
wouldn't would that be great just like
in their prime just get Holograms out
there can we create that could win you
guys out there create then you guys are
great at Apple or something can you guys
create at the time machine so we can put
those two guys together I think today
it'd be amazing but Mike was a killer
though he was a straight killer like he
wanted to hurt you he want to embarrass
you like refuse to lose ya refuse to
lose a very impressive man but LeBron is
doing is very impressive if he goes to a
straight finals appearances he amazing
his numbers are incredible like you look
at his numbers stuff that he's done now
he's made this team triple doubles like
he's very impressive I think Kobe gets
lost in this too right he got five
titles five titles he's probably the
closest as far as but he tried to be
Mike yeah he was pretty close LeBron
didn't did his way he's more magic he's
more of a hybrid but probably closer to
magic them yeah I would say that's ooh
all right the podcast
as you can tell very entertaining Carlos
Boozer the new podcast through Sports
Illustrated called hold dat with his
best friend Nate Robinson you can find
it on Apple podcast whenever you get
your podcast we'll come back we got our
play of the day we also have a poll
question as well Carlos thank you for
coming in our pleasure I appreciate that
much for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]